[Music]
my name is grant fleming
and i'm a data scientist at elder
research where i work
on data science consulting projects with
various public sector clients
and in that work along with a lot of the
work that i'm doing outside of
work work i'm having to wrestle with the
issue
of fairness and data science
specifically things like
how do we make sure that the predictions
being generated by our models are fair
how do we make sure we're actually
recording the correct information in our
data
and not leaving certain important
factors out and
if we suspect that something may have
snuck in our model
how do we make sure that we're able to
detect that element
before we deploy our model and cause
harm intentionally
because as we've seen probably in some
of the news over the past few years this
is an issue that's if not become more
widespread become more widely known
for example in 2018 joy buellam weenie
and her research team at mit published
the gender shades
work that they did on facial recognition
algorithms
from companies like amazon ibm
and others and in this work they found
out that these facial recognition
facial recognition algorithms were
actually
having much higher error rates detecting
darker skinned faces versus lighter
skinned faces
and that obviously is something that we
would not want to see
in any sort of fair model similarly we
saw something
similar in 2019 in the healthcare sector
where
an algorithm furnished to hospitals
throughout the u.s
which was tasked with
helping to allocate treatment to
patients within the hospitals
was systematically underestimating the
health care needs
for black patients relative to white
patients or patients from other
ethnic groups again likely a case of
unintended bias but nonetheless
something that led to harms
in the real world and i could spend the
mission talking about
these issues across the various
different examples which i'm not
including but
that's not productive maybe what's more
productive then is coming to an
understanding of
why this is actually happening so
from my perspective at least it seems
like this is in large part the result of
us as data scientists thinking that our
tools
alone the technical tools the code and
the data and the models that we
were able to build are enough to solve
these complex social problems
like duct tape we use them wherever we
can to fix
whatever we can and some situations are
helped by duct tape but duct tape
cannot alone solve everything i think
that's a good metaphor here for how
we should think about it or maybe how we
do think about it
how we should think about it instead is
our toolkit is not duct tape that should
be
used wildly wherever we can but rather
our tool kit
is one that along with people who have
the subject matter
and lived expertise in the areas that we
seem to operate in
they along with us can lay brick by
brick
a solution to a problem or at least get
closer to solving it
and this is twofold we from them can get
a greater appreciation for the factors
that can't be encoded in our data
or aren't encoding aren't encoded in our
data but are nonetheless relevant to our
work
and they in turn can help us
to better diagnose issues within our
models
before they're deployed sounds good but
how do we actually do this
how do we actually do responsible
ethical trustworthy however you want to
call it data science and practice
it's the million dollar question and a
number of researchers are
working to try and answer this and to my
reading it seems like they've coalesced
around the three main
factors that go into making a data
science project we'll just say
a responsible data science project those
being
first fairness and procedures so
basically was the project designed in
such a way that
it can be conducted fairly did it
include a diverse
range of voices and all relevant
stakeholders
next would be fairness in predictions so
when the model was actually built
does the model perform equally well
across different groups within the data
and the final one being fairness and
outcomes so
once the actual process of the model is
set in stone and is more or less fair
and even if we get
relative fairness in our predictions
does the impact of those predictions
actually
improve fairness in the real world are
the impacts of those predictions
equitable so fairness and outcomes
obviously something that's a little bit
harder to measure
maybe than the other two but we'll
attempt to talk about it at least a
little bit over the course of this
presentation
and the way we'll move forward with this
is
going through each of the three of these
in more detail
and we'll go through this in the context
of a practical example
but hopefully by maintaining all three
of these within our projects
if not doing our projects in a way that
is perfectly fair
we will get closer to a fair
responsible data science so
let's begin with fairness in procedures
and where better to start thinking about
that than
ensuring inclusion if you don't have a
diverse
perspective or diverse group of
perspectives on your project
in all likelihood something could slip
through
that would cause an unintended harm when
your model was deployed
this is especially relevant for someone
like me who
not only is a consultant who's often
coming into a data science project
in a subject matter context where i have
less expertise than maybe some of the
people i'm working with
but also because i'm a white man
and that comes that
bears with it certain biases um some of
them benign some of them harmful
and how i see the world and operate
within it
and it's important for me and the people
i work with on projects and the clients
i work with that
those biases are checked by the views
that other people can bring to the table
and i think critically this is something
that
is worthy in all projects and besides
being the right thing to do
next though would be reproducible code
we don't want code that just runs on
our on our own machines this is
maybe easier said than done but they're
fortunately within the r
ecosystem a number of packages available
for this
i won't go too much into detail on what
those are because
so many other people have already spoken
in depth about these
i'll reference two of them here the
first
would probably be dr anna cristali she
has a great talk
called putting the r into reproducible
research which you can find by googling
it should come up and then another
person karthik rahm delivered a talk
at the previous r studio conference in
2019 google that you should find it
i don't remember the title but between
the two of them they covered a lot of
really great materials for doing
reproducible work with nr
but back to fairness and procedures
finally to wrap this all up
we want to make sure that we document
everything we do and every decision we
make
in the same way that we want to have our
code be reproducible by technical people
we also want non-technical people who
may not be able to actually access our
code directly
to be able to pour through our results
in a way that's easy for them to
interpret and that they can actually
evaluate
in the google brain ethical ai team
has done a lot of good work on this
they've come up with
data sheets model cards and audit
reports
so three different sort of documentation
modalities that you can all think of is
nutrition labels
i guess for each part of the project and
even though we don't yet have any way to
do these within our
hopefully soon there will be some sort
of our markdown templates that make this
easier for us
i'm certainly on my own end trying to
put together a package for it and we'll
hopefully have some more updates on that
in the future
point being though if anyone wants to
look at good examples for these they can
google
the research done by timnit gebrew
deborah raji and megan mitchell
and for good examples of model cards i
specifically definitely recommend
looking up the tensorflow model card
toolkit
so tensorflow already has built-in
functionality for built-in model
building model cards and they have some
good examples for that there of things
that we may want to track
in our own work with that being done
you have a relatively fair process
in place and so you're in good shape to
start now thinking about
fairness and predictions starting with
predicting accurately
this doesn't need a whole lot of
development but i include this here to
make sure to point out that if you do
not
have high predictive performance overall
in your model
by no conception can it be fair even if
you perform equally across
groups getting a 10 level performance
across all of them
is meaningless and that's going to do
you and the people this model is hoping
to serve
no good whatsoever but more subtle and
probably more relevant to the work we do
is predicting equally and to explore
this
in practical detail and how we can
actually work on this in our own
projects
we're going to go through an example
with the compass recidivism data set
so this is a data set released by the
public interest group pro publica
and what it tracks is demographic
and criminal records information of
defendants
and the goal of this is to take all this
information and use it to predict
whether these defendants will commit
another crime in the next two years
because of the demographic information
within this data
it's often used as sort of the irs or
titanic data set for
fairness methods and evaluation of
fairness
maintaining approaches within data
science as we're about to do here and
as i already did here so on this plot we
can see
two different bars one for the accuracy
of a logistic regression
and one for the accuracy of a random
forest model
and again these are taking demographic
and criminal history features and
predicting a binary yes no
will commit a crime will not commit a
crime within two years
we can see that they perform roughly the
same
nothing nothing really jumping out here
which is why maybe we want to dig a
little deeper
maybe we can look at per group metrics
so
in this case instead of just looking
overall at overall model performance
we'll still look at the performance of
one model versus the other
but we're going to look at it with
respect to a protected feature
or sensitive feature in this case race
and then
the protected groups aka the levels of
that feature
which in this case would be hispanic
other caucasian or african-american
and already here we can see that there's
some differences or disparities
and performance coming to the fore with
african-americans specifically
the model getting the lowest accuracy
for
african americans relative to other
groups
this is already a pretty compelling
result i think
goes to show that overall metrics alone
are not enough to be able to
identify when you may have some issues
on fairness in your model
but we still don't necessarily know why
these disparities exist
these disparities have to be in part due
to different rates of error
and we don't know whether that's more
false positives or more false negatives
for the different groups
so let's actually look at plots of error
direction
and here is where we start to see the
real compelling
causes come to the fore here with in
this case the model
hitting a almost four times higher false
positive rate error for african
americans and caucasians
and similarly high rates for other
non-caucasian groups
this is clearly an issue bias and if we
were not to rectify this or
communicate this to our clients or
the non-technical people we're working
with in this project and we were to just
put a stamp on this and let it go in the
real world this would
perpetuate all sorts of biases that
would be harmful
and we don't want that
so to get a better context of that
before we actually communicate those
conclusions maybe we want to be able to
say
okay we've made every comparison between
every different group so caucasians with
african-americans caucasians with
hispanics
and maybe we care specifically about the
relative performance so we want to look
at the percent differences
that's where fairness metrics come in
they don't measure absolute performance
they measure relative
when we look at it in this plot here
it's still the same y-axis
still the same x-axis but now we get the
percentages
of false positive rates for each group
relative to the privileged group
caucasians
and again we can see here that there's
quite a lot of disparity
why though what is it in the features
that are going into the model that are
causing these disparities to exist
it's hard to get at causality at any
point within data science
but if we want to at least understand
more about how the features
impact these predictions differently
we're going to want to look at
interpretability methods
these are often explained in the context
of the black box
hence the image on the right what they
allow us to do
is open this black box because a lot of
these interpretability methods are model
agnostic
and they can be used even on models like
xg boost or random forest
to generate the sort of explanations
maybe not quite to the same level of
fidelity
but approximately that we would get from
a linear model
like a linear regression or something
like logistic regression
i'm not going to go through these in
detail within this presentation because
the visuals for them are a little
complex and we don't have a lot of time
but i will mention that they come in two
main varieties the first being global
methods which
explain the average effect of features
globally you can think of this as like
the coefficient of a regression
and if you want to read more about them
you can look up something like
permutation feature importance which
ought to be well known to a number of
people partial dependence plots
or individual conditional expectation
plots
we can also look at something in the
category of the local methods
and this could be say lime or shapley
values or derivatives of either of those
and these are really powerful because
they allow us to say for an
individual prediction on one observation
each feature value we can quantify the
exact amount that it contributed
to the prediction so if someone were to
ask hey why did i get this specific
classification from your model
you could tell them this feature
contributed this much this contributed
this much etc
a lot of useful explanation there
hopefully this is something that we can
end up
applying to most of our models and it's
certainly a set of techniques which are
well developed within the r package
ecosystem currently the iml package by
christoph mulnar
is available and i use it in my work and
i think it's fantastic
but there's also the vip and daleks
d-a-l-e-x
i believe packages which include a
number of interpretability methods as
well
and that all about wraps up the fairness
and prediction side
so again if you're able in your own work
to
ensure those three main points are hit
then you're well on your way to having
more fair predictions which then leads
us to the
thorny issue and possible future looking
set of solutions for fairness and
outcomes
and why is this future why is this
future leaning why is this a thorny set
of issues well
outcomes are all about the consequences
and how we consider fairness in the
context of the real world
because these outcomes and the impacts
they have on people are not necessarily
something that we can measure in the
data or at least can or
at least do measuring the data it's
something that requires conversations
not just with the people who maybe we're
working with who are non-technical
who have the subject matter expertise
for the projects we're working on
but also the people impacted by the
models and
talking with all these different groups
and coming up with some
conception of fairness to say okay
maybe we're going to optimize for
certain predictions
despite these predictions coming at a
loss of predictive performance for our
model
because ultimately that's the equitable
thing to do
that's something that's very project
specific it doesn't make a lot of sense
for me or anyone else to give any sort
of
real like definitive guidance on that
and just for
a little bit more detail maybe an
example to make this clear
you could think of fairness and outcomes
as being relevant in a case where maybe
we're granting
deciding whether someone deserves a
scholarship binary yes no
a yes would benefit someone who comes
from maybe a more disadvantaged
background
much more than someone who comes from a
more privileged background
and again that's not necessarily
something we measure within our model
but if it's something we want to try and
work towards then we need to make sure
to mitigate the bias that we see in our
model
in a specific way to serve that end
and that's where bias mitigation
techniques come in and i have the star
on the word there in the previous slide
because these techniques
they sometimes work well they sometimes
don't but by and large they all have
trade-offs
and that's because you're either
modifying the data
in the case of pre-processing that goes
into your models the model itself
or the predictions that come out of the
model to reach some notion of fairness
and while that may improve that specific
notion of fairness
you may see that there are losses in
predictive performance or fairness
across other dimensions
and to show this we'll go back and look
at the compass example
so here i have a plot again that shows
protected groups on the y-axis
and false positive rate on the x-axis
but now we're looking instead of at
logistic regression random forest we're
looking at just the random forest
but we're looking at two sets of
predictions here one
where the prediction thresholds are all
set at 0.5
for if you have a higher than 0.5
we'll predict that you will commit a
crime lower the opposite
and one that's set to an optimal level
for each class
such that it minimizes false positive
rate
and we can see here that it does that
well all groups actually have a large
decrease
in false positive rate which is great at
least
relative to each other we need to
actually go back
a few levels to look at the per group
performance
metrics on the absolute basis to see
what happened there
and when we do that unfortunately we see
that most of the
gains and fairness that we made in that
previous plot
are actually due to the error rate
mostly increasing
for the groups but increasing for the
other groups more than it did for the
african-american group
so basically what happened here is the
model said okay you want to make it more
fair
across groups for false positive rate
will make it so that the other groups
have more error
and make it so that the african-american
group their error relative to the other
groups is lower than it was originally
again if fairness is our goal here
that's that's fine that's not a bad
result
however it clearly did come with a
trade-off
and whenever we use these methods this
is just something we're going to have to
consider
lastly for fairness and outcomes we want
to consider
the possibility of algorithmic recourse
so if our models are making decisions
about people we don't want
them to lose the ability to actually
have some influence over that decision
they should be able to appeal it they
should be able to ask for explanations
as to why they were given that decision
and they should be given if asked or if
they choose to ask
recommendations for what they can do to
change it for more info on this i
recommend looking at the work of
ruha benjamin william isaac or shakir
muhammad
google any of those names and you'll
come up with a lot of good stuff
and at that point you've hit fairness
and outcomes
you've hit all three of the main notions
of fairness that have come up
across the research and you're doing
a solid job at doing data science more
responsibly
and fundamentally that's great because
doing data science in this way is the
right thing to do
there's a lot of good moral
justifications for why we should do our
work
with a greater conception for fairness
and consider factors
outside of the code and the data and the
predictions that we normally deal with
maybe as a profession we should start
thinking about thinking of ourselves
not just as data scientists but also
ethnographers
sociologists and anthropologists not
just thinking about it though
actually getting that knowledge and
that's something we should seek out
but beyond being right or beyond being
the morally right thing to do i also
want to make one more point
this is not just the right thing to do
doing these practices and doing data
science more responsibly in this way
is doing better data science by doing
responsible data science you'll build
better models
you'll have less errors sneaking through
to model deployment
and fundamentally you'll be serving all
the people that you're already serving
much better than you are now and with a
greater eye to safety and fairness
and if that's not worth doing then
i don't know what is so what i have here
to wrap up with are a few resources
additional links that people can look at
but
i have a number of other resources in
addition to code
to generate those plots and do a few
other analyses on the github
so if you're interested please do check
that out but otherwise
thanks for coming to the talk and for
sitting here with me and
hope to connect with you soon and
see you using these techniques yourself
best of luck
[Music]
you